Okay, welcome to another Zoom call.
We have new questions that got sent in.
Let's jump right into those first some announcements.
Please make sure you're checking the member's home page
for any announcements to a big announcements
that we've been talking about for a while.
And what is that starting January 1st?
We're going to drop back to just one Zoom call a week.
Remember, for those who you have been with, you have us.
We've only had one Zoom call a week Wednesdays at four o'clock.
We added the Monday one just a few months ago.
For several reasons that we now are just dropping that back.
So we won't have Monday's Zoom call any longer starting January 1st.
So we're back to just one Zoom call a week on Wednesday evenings.
And then we've talked about this multiple times.
New state laws have come out since the whole COVID thing.
COVID allowed us to do a lot of one-on-one calls with members questions
because the state boards basically dropped any mandates
about having to be licensed in a particular state
in order to do one-on-one calls.
Well, that has gone away now.
So we're back to doing making sure all our questions are only on
members of the Zoom calls.
Legally, we can continue to do Zoom calls that it falls under the educational
perspective as far as what we're doing with our members.
It doesn't fall on a doctor-patient relationship
which would constitute a like a telemedicine.
So legally, we can't do quote-unquote telemedicine.
So that was dropped during COVID.
So we had three nice years of being able to do one-on-one calls.
I don't even think anybody on this Zoom call has done one-on-one calls.
Maybe, maybe once or twice, but we can't do that anymore.
So your questions just have to come through some call,
which you're really doing that anyhow.
We've talked about this.
I remember to ask your questions on the site.
Instead of emailing those questions so they don't get lost.
I remember that you have free access to all the courses.
So take advantage of that.
Here's the list of the courses you can see that on our website.
Okay, first question.
I have breast cancer that has metastasized to the bone
just found out a couple weeks ago.
So we were starting nutrition to help with that.
But the last couple days, I've had a lot of tingly in my spine.
Do you know what that could be?
So tingly in your spine could that be?
The question really probably is,
could that be the cancer causing the tingly in the spine?
Well, it's quite, it's possible.
But more likely, there's probably other possible reasons too.
I know when you have cancer, I fall into this same bone.
Whenever I get symptoms, the first thing you think of is the cancer.
Is it getting worse?
Is it coming back?
Is it, you know, that process in my mind almost every day?
And I know it does for you guys too.
So, but what I have to keep reminding myself is that not all,
you know, as we get older, you just have some symptoms.
Sometimes it doesn't always mean that it's from the cancer.
But it's not bad.
That's a question.
You should kind of suspect like, oh,
am I doing something that could be aggravating my spine?
If I have the tastasis to the spine,
you do have to be more careful.
So, you shouldn't be doing, you know, pounding exercises.
You shouldn't be, there's certain things that you have to be more careful
when you got the tastasis in the bone,
because you don't want a pathological fracture.
So, when you have metastasis to the bone, typically it's what's called
lytic metastasis.
Typically it's, so lytic metastasis is where the bone is being
loaded, the broken down, or eaten away.
From radiology standpoint, it's often referred to as moth eaten.
Media looks like a moth has been chewed on your bone.
It's been referred to as rat bite lesions.
So, think of radiologists back in the day.
That's the kind of thing that they saw online, right?
So, it looks like some sublimal eat on your bone.
Well, that can weaken the bone.
So, you don't want to be putting extra force into the spine,
or the pelvis, or the femoral head, or something like that,
where you could have it up with them,
because of the weaker bone having a fracture.
So, it doesn't mean that every symptom you have is coming from your cancer,
so you kind of have to weigh that on and balance that out.
Also, I started using DMSO on Saturday,
when I received it over the liquid.
So, she's putting this over liquid iodide,
so she's putting liquid iodide on her breast,
and then putting DMSO over that help drive the iodide into the area.
Remember, I said, the person can use DMSO to drive something into your body,
because DMSO is so readily absorbed that it can bring with it other things.
You said I would taste garlic in my mouth with the DMSO.
My skin is tingly, which it should, because it's anti-inflammatory,
and it dries really fast, so you're going to tingly this of your skin.
My skin is tingly, but not getting that taste.
Am I using it up?
Yes, you will.
Some people are more sensitive to it and get that garlic taste,
because it's the sulfur and the dimethyl sulfoxide
that you get that garlic sulfur taste.
And it certainly is dose dependent.
So, when people used to use it for like knee pain,
they would really gobbin on all over their knee,
and you're going to get a strong garlic taste in your mouth,
but you're dabbing it on with a cotton ball.
Not quite so much.
Plus, it depends on how sensitive you are, too.
So, no, I don't think you should use more.
If you're not getting that taste,
you certainly don't need to have that taste.
I don't think that's working.
Okay, I will try to make this story short.
See what your thoughts on.
After I had COVID, I had a chiropractic adjustment.
The next day, I talked to my chiropractor
because I could hardly get on a bit.
She said that it wasn't, I wasn't out of place that bad
that I should be sore after the adjustment.
I thought it was probably from the COVID and achy body,
but after my bold skin,
at all the new lesions, the fracture on my hip,
I am thinking that this happened
when she was using the activator to adjust.
My back is really much better now,
and I know I still have it in my bone from the blood work.
But you tell me that these spots heal up a bit
or are just going to be weak.
I hope this makes sense.
So first of all, if you have the tasticist to the bone,
again, you're going to have lytic lesions,
these allotions in the body structure, which can weaken the bone.
And I highly recommend that you, if you're going to a chiropractor,
that you only get adjustments via an activator.
So these are low-force adjustments.
There's other different types of tools
that are low-force adjustments.
Some chiropractors have a technique
where they're just used low-force pressure.
They're not jumping, you know,
putting heavy pressure on your back,
quote-unquote, cranking your back.
You should, that's just my opinion,
but you should not get adjustments
that are manual adjustments
that cause a gaseous release
in that popping noise when you get adjusted
that you often get when you get manual adjustments.
You shouldn't do that.
You should only get activator adjustments.
I think that it would almost be impossible
for your chiropractor to hurt you with an activator.
So even if you have severe metastasis and severe lytic lesions,
I still don't think that the chiropractor could hurt you with an activator.
So I don't think that if the chiropractor
used an activator if I'm reading this correctly,
I don't think your pain is from the adjustment.
So I don't think that's it.
Now if you said that your chiropractor adjusted you manually
and then you found out you had metastasis,
first of all I don't think it's proper for a chiropractor
to be adjusting a person that has cancer
with anything but low-force adjustment
because he or she made a note that you have metastasis.
So just like this you went to the chiropractor not knowing you had metastasis.
I think professional conduct from a chiropractor should be
hey you have a cancer diagnosis
we're only doing low-force adjustment with you
because I don't know if you have metastasis or not.
Even if you go no no I had a pet scan.
I don't have metastasis.
Certainly if I was your chiropractor I'd still be doing only the activator.
It's just the right, I just think that's the right thing to do
for my professional ethics standpoint.
To not hurt the patient to first do your hard.
So if this chiropractor by reading this right, use the activator.
I think they did that correctly and I would not
hesitate to go back to that chiropractor.
I don't think that's the issue.
Okay, question on the chat.
I have been waking up nightly with night sweats.
All my clothes and bedding are wet too.
Is it good for me to eat a couple of garlic daily
if so is it better to eat raw or cooked garlic?
So night sweats with kids can be for multiple reasons.
You can get night sweats because
how the kids are can affect your hormones.
That can cause night sweats.
You can get night sweats because
of imbalance in your platelets.
That can cause night sweats and there is idiopathic night sweats.
Meaning that there's not a full-known cause of why
some cancer patients get night sweats.
Some cancer patients don't get night sweats at all.
Night sweats tend to be more common in certain types of cancers, blood cancers.
But it can be in other cancers as well.
So there's hormone causes, there's platelet and white blood cell,
imbalance causes, and then there's idiopathic classes.
Would garlic eat a couple of garlic help with that?
I don't know. Maybe you read that that might help with that.
I'm trying to think, let's talk my head, the physiological benefit of that.
Garlic can help with a lot of different things.
Garlic can be an antibiotic to your body, can kill pathogens.
Garlic can help reduce blood pressure and can help clean the blood.
Garlic can be an antibiotic in the blood.
It can help clear up infections on valves and things like that.
Garlic has some blood-thedying properties.
So you do have to be careful with garlic with blood-thedying
if you have any bleeding.
So if you have weeping in the tumor or bleeding in the tumor
and you increase a dose of garlic,
it's going to cause more blood-thedying
and that could be a danger.
So I would be cautious about that.
If you're on any blood-thedying medication,
you need to talk to your prescribing doctor of that medication.
People are going on garlic because of all the supplements.
No one to ban garlic has the strongest blood-thedying component to it.
And you should not also be taking garlic prior to a surgery.
So you should probably go off garlic a week before any type of surgery
because it will decrease clotting factors.
We didn't have a lot of questions come in.
The only questions that we had for today.
What is the day today?
Today we have two more.
Actually, one more Monday.
The next Monday will be the last Monday.
Maybe I will be in the day after Christmas.
I don't know.
We should be close today after Christmas.
So next Monday may be the last Monday we do to cause.
We don't have that many people on Monday.
So we call usually at least you guys are out here on Wednesdays too.
Any other questions we've probably been due for the day?
All right, hopefully you guys are all correct.
So they're Christmas.
You're planning some pilntimes with your families.
It's always a busy time of the year.
You can't negate the fact that you have an increased stress just because of that fact.
So they sure you're guarding yourself and you're protecting yourself and you're getting your rest
and you're taking the apps when you need to take the apps and you're really listening to your
body because you can be misled.
You don't really understand the inner stress it's going on inside of you.
You got cancer, you have lots of stuff going on and now you've got
holidays and Christmas and expectations and the family get together.
So all this good stress may be but it's still a stress to your body.
So don't ignore that.
All right, love you guys.
All I will see you in a couple days.